a couple weeks ago I got the chance to
play the new Lords of the fallen and I
gotta say the game is pretty good it
aims to hit basically all of the classic
action RPG souls-like elements from
exploration to item description lore to
strategic combat and it does a lot of it
really well when I reached the end of my
session I didn't want to stop playing
and right now I get to show off some of
the game to all of you and I want to do
it in a way where every type of player
can benefit so I'll start with a brief
overview of my experience followed by a
more in-depth look at some of the game's
mechanics if you want a spoiler-free
look and just want to know whether the
game seems like it's worth getting watch
the overview and if you want a closer
look at the mechanics and how they feel
to someone familiar with these kinds of
games watch the whole thing with that I
hope you enjoy the video and feel free
to subscribe to see more side note I
don't have any of my own captured
footage from the event just some
provided b-roll so I will do my best to
explain but what happens on screen will
not always be exactly relevant so Lords
of the Fallen begins how you may expect
a cinematic full of World building and
death you begin with a tutorial that
honestly throws a lot at you a bit too
much I would say as there are a ton of
mechanics to learn in the game but most
of them are pretty intuitive so once you
get playing it generally flows naturally
I got to play through the first few
biomes and bosses experience most of the
core mechanics and interact with a
number of NPCs that was all in just a
few hours and I am very excited to play
the rest of the game I think most people
looking for more content in the genre
can expect a pretty good time with Lords
it scratches the Soul's action itch in a
lot of ways and figuring out the combat
and new systems is a pretty enthralling
experience but the game is not perfect
as I said the tutorial is a bit
overwhelming with the number of
mechanics plus some of the first trailer
Impressions I've seen were people
commenting on the weapons seeming to
lack weight I definitely felt that while
watching some of the light class
gameplay but during my own playthrough
as a bog standard dude with a sword and
shield I was having fun the whole time
and I didn't get the feeling of my
weapons not being weighty enough the
combat plays into the genre's emphasis
on strategy and choosing your swings
always monitoring your stamina for
attacking and dodging the game features
a short evade and an almost comically
longer role if you press Dodge twice
shielding is strong since the game
features a pairing mechanic somewhat
like sekiro where if you block at the
right time you inflict posture damage to
your enemy eventually leading to a
critical hit the Perry ended up being a
really commonly used tool for me and
worked against a lot of enemies the
enemy designs include basic mobs but
also some interesting variations
especially since there are normal World
enemies those who fight in Axiom and
underworld enemies those you fight in
umbrella here we have one of the most
distinguishing aspects of the game the
two different worlds basically you have
your Overworld Axiom but there is a
second Shadow or underworld called
umbral
umbral is accessible through your
Lantern or by dying and getting a second
chance there and the only way out of
umbral is that specific lamp checkpoints
so it either serves as a second chance
to not fully die or it's a Zone you have
to willingly shift to to progress
throughout the game for instance doors
or paths may be blocked in Axiom but
open in umbral so you have to travel to
umbral cross and then try to find a way
back to Axiom further along when I
played I found the pacing between the
two zones to work out really well
throughout the full game the devs will
have to make sure that the swapping
doesn't get tedious but just based on my
demo umbral provided a tense change of
pace from the Overworld I found the back
and forth to be a lot of fun and of
course a game like this finds a lot of
its worth in its boss fights and for the
most part those were a good time too
some humanoids some not but a few times
the game got my heart racing I won't
detail too much in this section but my
only Chief complaint with the bosses was
that I wish most of them were harder and
more punishing and I did get the chance
to talk with some of the developers and
tell them that so maybe the final build
of the game will be closer to the
difficult and rewarding sweet spot and
with that I'm going to close the
overview section here if you are a Souls
fan and you're wondering if you should
get this game I'd say odds are looking
like a yes of course I'd also recommend
checking out full game reviews when they
come out near or on release but as a
player myself I'm pretty excited to play
more I think the game has some issues
some of which can be easily changed and
others less so but none of them are big
enough to get in the way of this being a
pretty good time and some of the deeper
mechanics if Done Right throughout the
whole game might turn it into something
special so I'll get more into the
details now so choose to stay or leave
depending on how much detail you want
a particular area I would like to delve
into to start would be the lore and
storytelling obviously my channel is
pretty big on that and I'm pretty
invested in that but because I didn't
have too long to spend with the game I
didn't explore the item descriptions or
story in general in much depth Lords of
the Fallen goes for the classic item
description story and laure tidbits but
I can't offer much review on the quality
of it here the game definitely sets
itself up to have the opportunity for a
rich world of Mythology with all their
ancient Demon Lord and Light Pillars
elements in the intro but the actual
execution and how deep things get I'll
have to wait to comment on beyond that I
want to start at the beginning as I
mentioned the tutorial throws a lot at
you there are plenty of controls Unique
Mechanics and game functions to get used
to and keep track of the devs said they
had been working on pairing the amount
of info down but I still found it to be
a lot and I didn't internalize
everything fortunately though most of
the important aspects come pretty
naturally so I didn't have to worry
about missing out on too much just some
of the more Niche moves among the
controls and mechanics the most unique
addition is the umbral lamp this is
basically what signifies you as the main
character of the game it is the reason
you can go into the umbral world and
respawn after death you can use it in
the normal World Axiom to attack enemies
or peer into umbral sometimes this lets
you get past walls or block paths but
other times you need to fully enter
umbral and the lamp lets you do that too
inside umbral you come across an almost
flood-like fungal world with additional
enemies the longer you stay there the
more enemies become aware of you and the
more dangerous it gets but at the same
time fighting through umbral gives you
more rewards than staying in Axiom not
to mention it lets you physically
progress in some cases the respawn
mechanic in this game uses umbral 2 and
it is kind of like sekido in that you
get two lives except here if you die in
Axiom you get sent to umbral if you die
in umbral that's it you get sent back to
the checkpoint so if you choose to go
into umbral with the lamp you lose that
second life again it's risk versus
reward and that interplay ended up being
a great change of pace for me when I
played it kind of works like a story
with two plot lines a good author knows
when to switch from one to the other to
keep the reader really engaged in my
play session I felt like the game did a
good job of going back and forth so I
hope the rest of the game keeps up that
Tempo and as a final point on umbral the
game gives two kinds of respawn
checkpoints the first are your normal
set locations throughout the game the
second are beacons you place yourself
around the Game World you can find some
small zones that have umbral flowers on
the ground here you can plant an umbral
seed to create your own respawn point
but the seeds are a consumable item so
you will only have a limited amount of
them at any time in my playthrough I
seem to have a decent view but I could
see it becoming a strategic decision on
where you want to place them or to
prioritize getting a lot of them to
place anywhere possible the the devs
also mentioned that new game plus might
have only these self-made respawn points
no set ones which would be quite an
opportunity for dedicated players
looking for a more difficult and player
driven experience the second time around
so that's a bit of groundwork now let's
talk bosses I get to play against a few
there was a tutorial boss designed to
kill you a couple humanoid bosses with
their own shtix and a final gargantuan
curse rotted great wood type to finish
out the session I was fortunately able
to play against and beat all of them so
I can give a more full review I'm no God
to your gamer but I did finish first out
of the group I was in and plenty of the
other press people there weren't able to
make it to the end so here is where
coming to a nerds YouTube channel might
be better than a standard gaming article
the first boss offered a normal beatable
Phase 1 followed by a phase 2
introduction to a new boss the light
Reaper I think is the name who is shown
in the intro cinematic and according to
the devs will appear multiple times
throughout a playthrough he is just
tanked with health so you will die in
the first fight you don't necessarily
have to but it will take a ton of
practice to be able to one shot him
especially at level 1. then there were a
few humanoids there was pieta someone
whose name I forget and the master of
hounds all were pretty fun and hit
different notes pieta was a 1v1 against
a Paladin sword strikes and holy magic
attacks which get beefed up during phase
2. she summons copies of herself and
large area spells pretty straightforward
and you get a decent sized flat bridge
to fight on giving it a solid spectacle
it's a fun and thematically weighty
fight pretty solid then the boss whose
name I forgot and who I don't think I
have any footage from was a flail
wielding sister in a more enclosed room
she included two ranged mobs who added
pressure to the fight plus a parasite
parasites are small umbral creatures
that show up occasionally and Grant
Buffs to enemies sometimes even giving
them invincibility so in the fight you
hunt down the parasite and destroy it
with your umbral lamp then you get rid
of the mobs and then you take out the
boss it's a pretty hectic fight and the
boss has a strong kit so it makes for a
bit of a thrill then another humanoid
with extra mobs is the master of hounds
an Archer who as the name suggests
summons a lot of dogs unfortunately for
me the Hound AI seemed a bit buggy so
the fight was pretty easy I didn't have
to worry about the hounds too much and
was able to chunk the main boss down
quickly the devs said they were aware of
this as an issue so hopefully it gets
updated before the release the arena is
a big wide open circle so if the hounds
do get updated to actually add pressure
it still won't be like Capper demon in a
super enclosed room with two dogs
and finally the last boss appeared just
when I was thinking to myself I could
really use a non-humanoid boss right now
as I thought that I was greeted with the
coagulator or coagulator or some other
word like that of Flesh also known as
the ballglord this is a massive rotund
enemy overflowing with flesh and
mutations it has wide reaching and
long-stretching arm attacks mixed with
poison emission big charge Dash grabs
and AOE slams plus there is an
occasional parasite buffing it too I
compared this to the curse rotted
Greatwood from Dark Souls 3 and I know a
lot of people didn't like that boss but
I meant the comparison as a compliment
since I like both and that linkage is
more of an overall feel since bug flesh
here doesn't have the only damageable
through weak spots mechanic so I think
if people don't like the curse rotted
Greatwood they still might like this
boss I really enjoyed this fight and it
pushed me to the brink of my health and
heartbeat I could get a breather by
moving back to range but it also had
attacks to make up the distance
unfortunately it seemed to have an issue
with its big charge grab where it
wouldn't grab me even though it looked
like I was really in the hitbox one of
the devs mentioned that they will be
widening that grab Zone which I am
actually happy to hear since there were
a few times I definitely should have
been more punished for my failed or bad
role I should have been grabbed but
because I managed to never get grabbed I
ended up beating his boss on my first
try so while it was a fun challenge I
could definitely enjoy it buffed up a
bit which might happen with the grab and
other potential changes more punishment
would make it feel more rewarding to
best even if it already did achieve that
feeling for me just a bit as it
currently is so that was my time with
the bosses now let's discuss some
mechanics the first one I want to
mention is a small one but it relates to
that last boss fight remember how he
said there was a parasite in the fight
occasionally buffing the main boss well
that being there actually allows for a
cool pretty deep healing mechanic to
take place
and Lords there are to my knowledge
three ways of healing first is through
your standard rechargeable upgradable
healing item your Estes second is
through an overtime life gem like
consumable and third is slightly more
complex through a few ways you can get
gray or withered Health basically a gray
bar on the right side of your health bar
that encroaches on the normal red Health
you get this withered Health from using
one of the lamps attacks healing while
you're in umbral and maybe other ways
that I currently forget and the gray
health is tentative if you get hit you
lose that health and only have your
remaining red Health but if you hit an
enemy first this gray Health gets fully
restored as red kind of like
bloodborne's rally mechanic but not as
immediate because it keeps sticking
around past a few seconds what's really
interesting here and something I didn't
pick up on while playing a Dev told me
about it later is that you can use the
withered Health as a strat during the
bog flesh fight I said there are little
parasites well when you Soulfly the
these enemies to destroy them you should
generate withered health and then you
should be able to turn that withered
Health Red by attacking the boss if you
are out of healing items and your health
is say halfway depleted you can use the
lamp on the parasites and you will take
on withered Health but this withered
Health starts from the right side of the
health bar so it isn't dependent upon
your current remaining Health it doesn't
start wherever your red is it starts at
the end of the bar and if you have half
Health it fills the empty Gap if you
wither the half of your bar that is gone
and then you hit the boss you will
effectively gain Health you generate
completely new healing I didn't get to
consciously try this but I might have
done it by accident while fighting since
I did run out of all my healing items
during the fight and now I want to get
into the game again and try this out
because it adds another deeper level of
strategizing and healing allowing you to
keep going even after your traditional
healing runs out if you can choose your
attacks wisely enough this is just the
kind of mechanic that I want to see that
really feels like it's trying to iterate
and improve upon the formula another
enjoyable yet simpler mechanic was the
Perry as I said parrying Works kind of
like sekiro where if you block right
before an attack you inflict what is
essentially posture damage enough of
this and you can get a critical hit on
an enemy I felt like the window was
pretty generous so it made pairing a
really strong tool fighting against most
enemies especially because I had a
shield so blocking was quick and easy I
don't know if they will tighten the
window for release but honestly I
wouldn't be opposed to something like
that if they wanted to either way it
offered a nice opportunity to have a
smart strategic play other than rolling
or Panic blocking increasing your
options in this case is almost always a
good thing to me and then an area of the
game that I didn't explore too much was
the utilization of throwables and Magic
which I believe are both tied to a
rechargeable ammo bar that sits below
the stamina bar on the HUD instead of
having throwables or ranged combat
depend on consumables the game gives you
an ammo bar that recharges when you rest
there are upgrades and consumables that
can better and augment this but the
basic design is one where you don't have
to worry about permanently running out
of supplies I believe magic works on the
same bar with your spells taking up
certain amounts of the resource there
are three kinds of magic in the game
basically like schools or Elemental
types each with a different Focus rogar
or fire is big on AOE radiant or holy is
focused on Co-op and status effects and
umbral or pure magic deals High Health
draining damage but I didn't use one
single cast of Magic during my play so I
can't comment too much beyond that and I
could have even gotten something there
wrong but I did mention Co-op So
speaking on that that I didn't play any
but the devs did say that there is a
seamless Co-op experience where you can
play with another player in one of your
worlds basically staying together for
the entire time throughout the game I
believe they said each person gets their
own loot so both can upgrade and make
builds while co-opping there does seem
to be a lot to find loot and upgrade
from normal RPG stats to your weapons
and healing items to even the umbrella
lamp you can give it different abilities
and more charges to suck the souls out
of multiple enemies that could mean good
rewards for exploring which would be
ideal since exploration and tracking the
branching Paths of the game World seem
to be a big focus in when I played lots
of doorways to open and areas where you
Circle back into through A New Path the
different biomes I was able to see
highlighted a good amount of level
design variety both in visuals and how
you play through them they all had
umbral versions which were necessary to
enter into to fully Traverse but they
had their own style too there was a
forested mountain region and a village
which played differently than the more
vertical Cliffside settlement in caves
within each area itself some of the
visual design did seem to blend together
just color wise but I didn't focus
enough to determine how big of an issue
that was I was definitely more keyed in
on exploring for items and slicing my
way to the next objective or boss if I
get to play more before release or for a
review I'll spend more time considering
that and while that covers a lot of my
experience and the fun I had there are
more issues that I partially have
touched on but should detail more
clearly I've seen a good amount of
discussion mentioning how the weapons
look or sound pretty light like they
lack weight I didn't experience this too
much while playing with my sword and
shield but watching the footage of some
of the lighter weapons like the daggers
I see where people are coming from I
thought that some of the other parts of
the game had really good sound design so
I would hope this gets addressed before
the game's release I'm assuming devs are
looking at comments online and I saw a
lot of comments about this so I would
think it's at least getting discussed to
be potentially addressed and I already
mentioned the tutorial throwing a lot of
information right at the start but I
also felt that way when I first got to
the hub area now maybe they just wanted
to show everyone off since it was a
press event but there felt like way too
many NPCs at the Hub when I got there
there were so many people to meet for
the first time all at once that I didn't
really internalize a lot of them and I
got to see at least one example of
finding an NPC in the world and sending
them back to the hub and that made them
a lot more memorable and distinct when
compared to the dozen or so that were
already hanging out there overall I
think this game is checking a lot of the
boxes that people expect in the genre
but I'm hoping it's able to also
capitalize on what makes it its own
experience I think the potential is
there it does already stand out to me
thanks to some of the deeper mechanics
like the advanced healing and the two
World split being fun and what I've
played but the full game will need to
make those things last and stand out
throughout the whole experience I'm
really excited by what I've gotten to
see and play so far there's a bit of
Jank and some minor to moderate issues
but I can look past most of that thanks
to the large number of positives and
because it at least sounds like the devs
are making updates in the right
direction as we and I get more info over
the next few weeks and months I'll let
you know if that opinion changes or
solidifies the next few months really
seem to be packed to the brim with good
gaming news especially for from soft
fans and the hyped to explore it all on
my channel so feel free to subscribe if
you want to see more thanks to my
patrons for supporting me and thank you
for watching this video peace